this is a production of cornell
university
thank you
great crowd so happy to be here this is
actually my fourth trip to new york this
year as national teacher of the year
i've been here all day at the university
spoke this morning actually at ithaca
college with ithaca college faculty and
also faculty from cornell this afternoon
had a chance to speak with education
majors from cornell and i'm here with
you tonight to give you a little bit
more broad perspective not just about my
background personally but what i've been
doing this year's national teacher of
the year and what the conversations are
that are going on in america right now
related to public education and sort of
how we can all be a part of that so i
really appreciate you coming out tonight
and i want to start by telling you just
a little bit about myself as was just
mentioned um i did go to princeton
university and
growing up i thought i always wanted to
be a teacher my mother's a retired
elementary school teacher and in general
i thought being a teacher would be a
really great thing to be
that career goal was sort of received in
a lukewarm fashion until i decided to
enroll at princeton university and then
the conversation really changed and then
the conversation became well you know
those who can do and those who can't
teach
and i was asked when i got to princeton
well
you know you came to princeton and all
you want to be is a teacher
and what a waste
and i know that some people here at
cornell can relate to that uh philosophy
and dr duff actually sitting up front
here is a fellow princetonian we
actually graduated from each other one
year apart and he thought it would be
nice for me to come here and kind of
share my perspective on how and why i
got into teaching despite
considerable social pressure not to do
so but it really all goes back to
this journey here i did start
volunteering
i decided when i was at princeton that
okay well maybe i should be something
more so i decided to be pre-med
and in general that career goal was very
well received so everybody else was
happy and i was plodding along planning
to be pre-med took the mcats did the
whole nine yards and i thought to myself
well you know if i'm not going to do
teaching as a career then by golly i'm
going to go volunteer
and i found myself in this classroom at
the new jersey school for the deaf
with these students who changed my life
they changed my life and people ask me
they said well you know what was it
about that environment what was it about
being with those students that made you
completely scrap your pre-med plans and
decide to go into teaching and for
anybody who's ever been in a classroom
it's easy to understand because there's
this energy
there's this interaction knowing that
you're making a difference every day i
just really wanted to be a part of that
and so i came from this environment
to where i am now
and this is a snapshot from my classroom
at urbana high school in frederick
county maryland
i've been teaching at the school
approximately a total of about 11 years
and i love this picture and i love to
tell people what i see in this picture i
look at this picture i see progress
because i see roughly an equal mix of
male and female students
and remember this is an ap chemistry
class
and that is not always the way it used
to be we are starting to close the
gender gap in some of our advanced
science subjects particularly in
chemistry and biology we have more work
to do in physics and math and
engineering but we're making progress i
look at the picture and i see some
diversity but not enough
because the diversity of my own
classroom still does not reflect the
diversity of my school and that's a
problem and our work is not finished
until it does
but students in my class who have 504
plans or ieps which means they have some
form of special needs over the years
i've accommodated students in my
classroom with everything from
asperger's syndrome to dyslexia
dysgraphia low vision and people tell me
sometimes that those students really
have no business being in my class
because it's an ap chemistry class
and that should mean something
and perhaps my expectations just aren't
high enough
i also look at this picture and i see at
least one face that's missing and it's
because that student is at the career
and technology center the vocational
student and somebody asked me well why
would a student in the vocational
program be in your ap chemistry class
that's a conflict
and my question is why is there only one
i mean with all the overlap between
taking knowledge and applying it which
is what i do in my chemistry classes
what they do in the vocational program
and aren't we really all teaching the
same things that we should be able to
make some more progress there
so in between in the middle of my career
i had the opportunity to teach at the
maryland school for the deaf and this is
a snapshot of a group of students that i
taught while i was there maryland school
for the deaf is a very interesting place
even though that maryland is a small
state it's a very diverse state and this
school draws students from all over the
state so students from our inner cities
students from our eastern shore the
beach areas students from the mountains
and everything in between and not just
students from different socioeconomic
backgrounds but students who have
different varying levels of hearing loss
so for example i taught some students
here who were born deaf and grew up with
families using american sign language i
taught other students who were not
diagnosed with their deafness till much
later in life so they came to me at the
high school level maybe not knowing any
sign language at all and of course at
this particular school all of the
instruction was through american sign
language we didn't use voice at all so
sometimes in my chemistry physics class
i would have a student who maybe was
growing up with spoken spanish in the
home had no idea about asl but yet we're
in my chemistry and physics class trying
to learn through asl so it's a very
complicated dynamic situation
so basically you know i've been hanging
out the better part of the past 15 years
you know teaching everybody's favorite
subject
and i can see that that's true here by
the show of hands about how many of you
this is really favorite subject and of
course i'm just kidding obviously
chemistry is not everybody's favorite
subject
but as educators as a teacher it's my
job to somehow bring this to everybody
and usually when people hear chemistry
they think of one of two things they
either think about the facts and the
formulas that they despise so much
or they think about the fun stuff they
think about the fun stuff and yeah
there's fun stuff in chemistry you know
my students love to do lab activities
and of course i try to engage them in
everything that i can when students come
into my classroom really every day they
want to know two things right they have
two questions for me first they want to
know
are we going to burn something today
that's number one and if we're not going
to burn something the question is are we
going to
blow something up
right that's what students want to do in
a chemistry class and so yes as a
teacher trying to engage my students i
try to bring them in any way that i can
i know that most of my students are
really into the harry potter series
and they've seen the movies and they see
that big green flu network do you know
what i'm talking about if you've seen
the movie and they know that's chemistry
and they say oh that's so cool you know
can we do that in your class and i say
sure we can do that and we set up little
green flu networks all over the counter
tops and then they see how they burn
green and they say oh you know can we
make them red and i say yeah we can do
that you know and then we turn them red
and then they want to know why and then
you can actually teach them something i
have students in my class who swear up
and down that they are not science
people you know i am not a science
person you are not going to turn me into
a science person they say i am a history
person and i said well that's fine you
know there's a lot of science in history
we talk about things like the hindenburg
explosion and all of my history buffs
can tell me all about that and they've
seen the video and they've read the
theories and then they say yeah that was
a really amazing explosion and then they
make the connection and there's the
explosion can we do that can we do that
in your classroom and i say yeah sure we
can do that we can take balloons and we
can fill them up with hydrogen gas and
in a carefully controlled situation
we can explode those little mini
hydrogen balloons so they can get a
sense for what that history was like
i've never met a student from anywhere
who doesn't want to set off an alcohol
cannon
it's just one of those universally
appealing things
and as teach as a teacher i would be
crazy not to tap into that but you know
it's not all about fun and games and
entertainment it's really so that our
students wind up with a serious look on
their face so that they get engaged
better yet to have this look of pride on
their face and i love this particular
picture because rochelle's lab work is
reflected in her goggles with that sense
of pride of having mastered something
really truly difficult and with
everything that we know about data these
days and there's a lot of talk in
education about data
data action research collect the data
what does it mean and that's all
important but i've learned over the
years and having starting in deaf
education that i get just as much
information out of looking at students
faces and that's something that i've
done all along but then last may 3rd i
found myself in a very unlikely place
for a public school teacher
with the president of the united states
to my right and the secretary of
education to my left standing with
the 55 state and territorial teachers of
the year
and knowing in that moment that i was no
longer a chemistry teacher hanging out
in my classroom blowing up stuff and
doing cool labs with my students
that i was now a spokesperson for public
education representing all teachers
early childhood teachers elementary
school teachers middle school teachers
high school teachers from all subject
areas and it would be my job for a year
to find the themes that connect us all
now as a little time out you might be
thinking
how exactly do you wind up in that place
i mean really how would you get chosen
for something like that what is the
process and i'll just make a long story
very very short but it actually started
at my school level the faculty that i
worked with in my school nominated me
put me on the ballot to apply for
teacher of the year and i told him i
didn't want to do it
i said i want to do it because it would
take too much time
away from my students because with any
process like this it's a process there's
a lot of essay writing there are
face-to-face interviews
and all the while you never think that
you're going to go very far anyway so i
did start the process because i was very
honored to be to be nominated and then i
was named teacher of the year at my
county level in frederick county and
maryland and then all of the county
teachers went to the state level and
then i went through another series of
evaluations at the state level and then
i was named the maryland teacher of the
year
and then once you're named your state
teacher of the year then all of those
application materials get sent to the
national committee and at that point the
game changes a little bit because at
that point if you're your state teacher
of the year it's pretty much a given
that everybody's fabulous in the
classroom everybody's doing amazing
things in the classroom and so from that
pool of 55 four finalists were selected
of which i was one we were all brought
into washington dc and in washington dc
we were put through a series of
evaluations that would simulate what we
would do as national teacher of the year
we had a classic interview where we had
to answer questions
we had to do a mock tv interview like a
good morning america we had to do a
press conference i had to do a keynote
speech we had to do a working networking
dinner
so different situations that would
evaluate our ability to be a
spokesperson which is what this year is
all about
people look at this picture and they
think that i have a direct line to the
president and the secretary of education
i do not
i do not everything that i do is by
invitation
and it's not a role where you are seated
with the policy makers that's not the
purpose of the year though i have had
some opportunities to interact with them
both that's certainly not the focus but
i have as i like to say
just been teaching in a larger classroom
i mean i've told myself all along that
the key word in national teacher of the
year is teacher you know i'm still a
teacher i'm always a teacher i've always
considered myself a teacher but i have a
much bigger classroom much bigger
audience this year if you look at the
map
everything that's shaded in hot pink
shows you where i have been as national
teacher of the year and many of those
states multiple visits i mean four
visits to new york three to texas three
to mississippi um history people please
forgive me geography folks but yes china
and japan floating around there
aimlessly in the ocean i have been to
china and japan obviously the map is not
to scale
also heading to singapore at the end of
may so that'll be three international
trips on my schedule you see that
arkansas is shaded orange instead of
pink that's because i took a virtual
trip to arkansas
i went to arkansas via skype
and i spoke with a group of teachers
about this large just through the
screens so pretty amazing how technology
is really bringing people together and
in yellow you see the states that i will
continue to visit and speak in even
after my term officially ends on june
1st and you say well
how come you didn't go to nevada and how
come you didn't go to minnesota remember
it's all by invitation i can't decide so
for example i'm still waiting on an
invitation to hawaii
i'm still waiting i'd love to go i think
i have a lot to say to educators there
but unfortunately that just hasn't come
through so it's all by invitation and to
some extent invitations uh there are
conflicts so for example i was scheduled
to go to south dakota but then the japan
trip came up so then the south dakota
event fell off my schedule so those
sorts of things happen
but basically as i go around the country
not only am i sharing what i'm doing and
what's going on in education i'm
learning and also i'm i'm answer asking
asking and answering a lot of questions
and what's interesting is as i travel a
lot of the questions that i get asked
particularly by the media are of a very
urgent
point-blank nature for example this is
the first question i was ever asked in a
phone interview
what's the secret
right
what's the secret
to teaching of course
as if i have that secret you know
written down on a little piece of paper
and folded up and in a lock box in my
classroom and if i would somehow just
let it out
then somehow everything would be okay
what's the secret here's another one why
can't we fix our schools
right why can't we just fix our schools
and by the way give it to me in 20
seconds or less because that's all you
have for this sound bite
because we do live in the sound bite
culture
and people are only willing to listen
for so long
and so
i've learned as every state teacher and
national teacher has learned that if you
have something to say to the media you
better say it quickly make your point
because otherwise the conversation is
going to change very quickly i love this
one this next question is yes yes yes i
understand that there are so many
challenges in education but
if you had a magic wand
i love that if you had a magic wand
and i got to a certain point where i had
been asked that question so many times
that i just flat out said in an
interview i don't have a magic wand no
one does
i mean that's the truthful answer
that is the truthful answer
it was on public television in fact
nobody has a magic wand
it's just not that simple and i know
that here in america we like that quick
fix we want that easy answer we want to
try to pretend that there's just one
thing that could make everything right
despite the diversity of our nation and
it's not just true but i understand that
these questions are all designed to get
at what the real issue is and the real
issue is how do we reach all students
that's what really weighs on everybody's
mind is the equity issue we we still
admit that in our country there are
pockets of excellence that's for sure
and then there are pockets of great need
and that there are huge disparities in
access and resources for students
sometimes the disparity is separated by
just a matter of miles
and and everybody's trying to figure out
why that continues and what we can do
about it but but it's it's a good
natured question i mean how do we reach
all students and you know now that i'm a
parent myself
this question is very very important to
me this is my little girl carly
and she's sitting with the boy she says
she's going to marry
and they are at their preschool
graduation
yeah their preschool graduation
and i noticed that some people in the
audience said oh like it's not cute and
that's great and some people laugh when
i say that
they're like preschool graduation like
are you serious like how silly to which
i say you know is it really that silly
is it really that silly if we're going
for equity here that from the youngest
possible age to have absolutely every
child wear that cap and gown and hold
that piece of paper so that they will
believe
that they too will be what we're calling
these days and you've probably heard the
term college and career ready
and i put that in quotes because we're
not going to debate it at the moment
but the point is that if we think about
our own children or a child very close
to us in our lives we know exactly what
that means
i know what it means for my daughter to
be college ready career ready life ready
world ready i know everything i want her
to be in my mind i don't need to see it
spelled out on a checklist i don't need
it to be in a manual or a curriculum or
a set of standards i know
what that is
and you know her little boyfriend i
don't know him very well
but
it's my job as an educator
to want for other people's children
what i want for my own
and as we work towards this equity that
we all desire so much i think if we can
just keep that very simple fact in mind
that moves us a huge step forward
so just to give you an idea of how that
conversation is playing out over the
country i'm going to take a week from my
schedule as national teacher and just
show you the different conversations
that i'm involved in and i can't
necessarily say that this week is
typical but it'll give you an idea of
some of the things that i've been doing
if we flash back to november um first i
was involved in a conference week
regarding educator effectiveness big
deal right now is about teachers and how
we're going to evaluate them and what
makes an effective teacher and what
makes an exceptional teacher and how do
we spell that all out in a form that's
somehow fair and perhaps could be linked
to compensation that's a big issue so my
day on monday november 14th started with
that issue and then i went down to
washington dc for congressional briefing
where we were talking about the ap
chemistry redesign curriculum is a big
issue in the in the discussion uh in the
country right now what are we going to
teach kids and even something uh with a
long strand standing tradition like the
ap programs they're even looking at
their curriculum and redesigning it and
trying to make it less facts more
application less memorization more
inquiry so the tests are changing
everything's changing really effective
immediately so i was weighing in on that
then i went to a women's heritage center
for a stem exhibit again equity is still
on everybody's minds we're trying to
figure out how do we get more women into
stem science technology engineering
mathematics how do we get more
individuals from minority backgrounds
into stem and so any event that kind of
highlights that is something that i
would be involved in you know we need to
celebrate what's going on in our public
schools so that we know what to
replicate and to emulate you turn on the
news on any given night and you hear a
lot of things that we're not doing right
in the public schools i mean that
dominates the conversation but there are
a lot of celebrations that go on and
it's it's very important because
otherwise we don't know what's truly
working so i found myself at the blue
ribbon schools
ceremony
with arne duncan celebrating great
things happening and then i found myself
later that day again celebrating
american education week because it's
really important that we get these
positive stories out in the news
i mean i i suggested in my national
teacher of the application i mean
imagine if the national news began each
evening with a segment titled highlights
in american public education
that actually celebrate what's really
working that's really going on that's
good in our public schools
not only would we be celebrating it but
we would know what to emulate and what
to replicate we don't know enough about
the great things that are really going
on as i travel the country people say oh
michelle have you heard about this going
on here have you heard about this
program and i say yeah no i i really
haven't
because we don't get that message out
there nearly enough so that's obviously
an issue of concern the next day i found
myself with students i found myself with
a little people
at a local elementary school i was
speaking to kindergartners first graders
all the way up to fifth graders and
their parents and what i found really
interesting at that student assembly and
you know there's a different situation
for me because remember i'm a high
school teacher but you know they
corralled them all into the cafeteria
like you probably remember when you were
in elementary school and everybody was
sitting in nice neat rows just like
their teachers told them with their legs
folded you know crisscross applesauce
and all that
and
they're all looking up at me
and you know when i grabbed the mic that
day
i actually hesitated for a minute before
i started speaking because i thought to
myself man
you know i better be good
because i've got the future sitting
there staring back at me
and whatever i say is going to stick in
their brains and i better be good
and i asked them some questions that day
now i'm not full enough to open up a
question to you know 500 kindergarteners
and have them all call out and screaming
but i taught him a little bit of sign
language i told him yes and i taught him
no and i asked the kindergartners i
asked them if they thought i looked like
a scientist
and over half of them said no
now tell me why
a five-year-old
would would tell me that i don't look
like a scientist i mean on what basis is
it because i'm a woman is it because i
have long hair and it's kind of curly
how do these images and these
perceptions gets ingrained in our
children so early
and little kids are very honest so
they'll tell you that so we really have
some work to do in our country with
perceptions starting from our very young
children and believing you know who
could be a scientist who could be a
college graduate you know who could be a
professional
you know we need to do a lot with
perceptions later that day i found
myself with my own little girl
at her parent day at her school and then
i caught a plane to go to phoenix and in
phoenix i went to a policy conference
when i go to a policy conference i'm
usually the only teacher there
i am the
teacher voice
the teacher voice
and in that particular situation at this
particular event we went on a tour of a
vocational school you know we have a lot
of students in our country who are on a
vocational track this is just a fact and
we have to serve their needs we also
have to understand our vocational
students because vocational students
also have college plans i got news for
you and often they have very big goals
and they have it all figured out because
they explain it to me they say yeah i'm
going to graduate from high school i'm
going to get this job i'm going to save
money then i'm going to go to college
then i'm going to go back and start my
own business so
it's very unfair of us
to put people on tracks and say well
you're either vocational or you're
academic because there's so much
crossover so i'd have a chance to go to
that school or chat on educator
effectiveness a little bit of networking
and then finally i was done
giving my own keynote and you might
think about this week that i just
described and somebody asked me once
they said what do you do when you get
sick
it's just not on the schedule it's just
it just doesn't happen you just um
fortunately i've had a very good year
but i've not gotten sick but that
particular week i got to go home on
sunday and you say well that's nice you
get at least you get to get home every
sunday no i don't get to go home every
sunday it just happened that that sunday
i got to go home and i've appreciated
everybody who's asked about my family
obviously this is a tremendous sacrifice
for my little girl and for my husband
and
people ask if my family can travel with
me and they really can't because they
have their lives in maryland you know my
little girl's in school she's in first
grade you know she's working on her art
she's working on her public speaking
she's working on her little science
experiments
there's my husband who's currently
winning the husband of the year award
as i travel 80 90 percent of the time
and there was one time in november or
december where they did get to travel
with me to arizona
nbc was having a big celebration of
education it had happened to be at an
nfl event we had never been to an nfl
game before so this was a quick two day
trip of course we got all the gear and
and we do wear that gear back in
maryland even though we are in steelers
and our ravens territory we we boldly
wear that cardinals here back at home so
every now and then um you know they
might be able to join me for something
but usually i'm off on my own i spend a
lot of time at universities and colleges
cornell is obviously not my first i've
done a lot of colleges and universities
over the course of the year and i see a
lot of interesting things going on a lot
of the conversation is the same how do
we best prepare our teacher candidates
last week i was at ole miss
and they took me to a room
where i saw this on the screen
has anybody seen this before
i thought wow what is this this is
something called teach live that
actually came out of the university of
central florida
and basically it's a classroom an empty
classroom with a screen
with
digital avatar virtual children
and these children on the screen can be
programmed
to have different personalities
different learning challenges
and the idea is that a teacher in
training
will step into that room with the
students on the screen
and practice teaching them
before they get in front of live
children
this is new to me
i just saw this last week
i don't know what i think about it
because i'm still trying to reflect and
process it but as i say when i travel
not only am i sharing things from my own
perspective but i'm learning about the
different things that are going on and i
tell you things are really rapidly
changing in education
i was at manhattanville college in
purchase new york talking with teacher
candidates there went to kent state ohio
talked with then i came back to new york
for a stem panel and again this is
another situation where i am the only
teacher on the panel and then a little
bit more with career tech and on to
texas so it gives you an idea of kind of
the schedule and things that people are
talking about i think one of the most
valuable experiences for me this year's
national teacher is to be in close
contact with the business community
and hear about what they want our
students to be able to do and it's a
very different conversation often that
we're having in the education world you
know where we are in education right now
we talk a lot about curriculum and
testing and scores and standards very
interesting to have conversations with
people from the business world who have
a whole different set of expectations
for our students
and sometimes they'll say point blank
you know i don't care if you have a
straight a student who can get fives on
every ap test
if they can't also
step up and take a leadership role
work with self-confidence
be resilient and adaptable and
reflective
and independent and resilient and all
these other factors that they want our
students to be in fact i went to a
science facility in spokane washington
and i point blank asked the researchers
there i said if i could transport you
back to urbana high school to talk with
my students what would you tell them is
the most important thing that they need
to succeed in your scientific facility
and one of the researchers said the
ability to think critically and to
analyze and to reason and one of them
said the ability to solve problems
creatively to work without a manual to
move forward you know even when things
go wrong and then the third said
something very interesting she said your
students need to be able to see beyond
themselves
to see beyond themselves
and that's very interesting perspective
and as we teach and we think about how
we're going to teach all these different
things i mean where where is the app for
that where is the technology that's
going to help me teach my students to
see beyond themselves
but there's all these expectations that
our students are going to have as
finished products when they graduate
from high school when you graduate from
college that people are going to expect
you to be all these things and that
somehow through education we're
providing all of that and it kind of
sums up here in a visual like this
you know as we go about curriculum and
objectives and testing and mastering
material
we also have to be thinking about all
these things in every subject area
literacy and problem solving
communication presentation critical
thinking and i tell you it's that little
blue box self management
that's what people really want
when you graduate from college you
graduate from high school to have all
those interpersonal skills
and you know that's a lot to teach it's
a lot to teach but we're not
having
conversations going on on the other side
of the world had the opportunity to go
to china
met with the director general of
education in china and they're having
some of the same conversations
um specifically they need great teachers
too
because they have a lot of people to
educate and we said well what are you
doing to get great teachers into the
profession and they shared that a few
years ago they started a program where
they were offering full scholarships to
talented students
in exchange for a 10-year commitment to
teaching
that's quite a commitment
we don't have anything here in the
united states that that rivals that or
matches that a 10-year commitment to
teaching they also talked about the dire
need to have teachers in the rural areas
that's a similar situation that we have
here in the u.s not being able to get
teachers for certain
regions had the opportunity to visit
with some vocational students had the
opportunity to meet with a chemistry
department at bayi high school and it's
very interesting because when i went to
china
based on what i hear from the media i
thought that we'd be having a
conversation about test scores right
because that's what the media likes to
talk about everybody's test scores and
comparing each other you know what
that group of teachers didn't want to
talk about test scores they didn't even
bring up test scores they had all sorts
of questions for me about
how do you encourage students to be
creative thinkers
how do you encourage students to come up
with original ideas how do you encourage
students to innovate how do you get past
paper and pencil exercises because they
really see the shift
in the world as it's changing today that
whoever can do all that can innovate and
be creative that they're going to have
the advantage and they're really looking
for ideas for how to make that happen
there had the opportunity to talk with
some teachers this young lady i was
sharing with the education students
today i asked her what it's like to
teach in china how she would describe it
and she just came up with one word she
just says it's tiring
it's tiring and anybody who's ever
taught understands why that word was
used tiring and we talked a little bit
with the students today went on to japan
met with the deputy minister of
education in japan the very first thing
he wanted to talk about was how do we
get stem into the elementary school
years
realizing that high school is too late
to start getting students interested in
serious science and what were we doing
to bring science education to the
elementary school levels and of course
that's a struggle for us here
in a lot of areas
even in my daughter's elementary school
science is still pushed to the back
burner because we have this focus on
testing and common core standards of
course are coming on and that's giving
you know even more focus to english and
of course math and so when do you do the
science but yet everybody wants all
these scientists for the future how are
we going to create them if we don't
start from the youngest possible age and
in japan they realize that that's an
issue as well i took a little japanese
in college so i had a little bit of
working knowledge
they welcomed me warmly with the
traditional tea ceremonies and all of
that so that was really nice had a
chance to visit a broad range of schools
in japan they were very very eager to
show me everything took me to something
they called a super science school a
super science school and this is one of
these highly selective schools that has
absolutely everything all the latest
technology
all of the you know on-site research
facility and when we drove away from
that school my host said to me i want
you to understand that that is the
exception
that that is the exception and then i
visited many other schools that you know
would be comparable to many of the
schools that we have here you know good
schools but not necessarily the latest
of everything they also took me to a
school that served students with special
needs and students that have issues with
truancy and trying to figure out how to
include those students in
the system and i think probably the most
people say what's been the highlight of
your year what's been the moment that's
been the most impactful i would have to
say it would be the end of my trip where
i went to onagawa city japan now because
this is such a large screen i think
you're going to be able to see what i'm
getting at and we'll zoom in in a minute
but they took me to a region that had
been devastated by the tsunami
and at the very beginning of the week
you know i had a full schedule of events
you know i had to meet with the minister
and i had to give presentations and meet
with teachers and all that they said at
the end of the week the very last thing
they said would you teach a class
to our students
they said we have this group of students
uh we'll bring in with some sixth
graders they have lost everything will
you come teach a class and so of course
somebody says teach class and i haven't
taught for many many months and so i
start thinking i start thinking about
the labs we can do i start thinking
about what i'm going to need and the
curriculum i said you know what do you
have and they said nothing
so we don't have anything
but they still wanted me to create this
magical amazing moment for their
students and again just to give you a
little bit of a picture if we zoom in a
little bit you know this was still the
situation when i was there in october
after the tsunami hit in march i mean
everything just completely pushed off
into piles it really cannot be captured
uh by a camera but where there were
buildings standing still debris just
strewn all over the place everywhere um
you know people's personal belongings
just still scattered you know amidst the
streets and i was led around by this
this wonderful man a teacher who's
actually standing on the site where his
home was washed away
is his home was standing where the
yellow flowers are and he's pointing up
to the school and of course the school
being high on the hill
the lives of the students and the
teachers were spared because the tsunami
hit
at 3 30 in the afternoon
while many of their parents and the
workers in the village below were just
washed away
and so this was the school he asked me
to go teach in
and again i thought wow you know if i'm
going to make this great we got to have
something i said well what can we do so
we spent the entire week
just trying to round up the materials
for for one one hour lab and you know i
talked to my students at urbana about
this when i visited in january i said
when you think about what you have the
access the resources the choices
everything that we have here this is all
yours to take advantage of i said it
took us a whole week like six adults
scrounging materials for one lab and i
asked for scissors i asked for rulers i
asked for aluminum foil and trays you
know very basic stuff and i asked them
if they could get me some bubble gum i
said because if you can get me some
bubblegum remember this is sixth grade i
thought we could do a cool experiment
where you
figure out the percentage of sugar in
bubble gum and i said you know that
would be really fun for them and my host
said well you know i don't know i i
don't i don't know if we can get bubble
gum and even if we get it i don't know
if our students are going to know what
to do with it
because you know it's not like america
where kids just walk into the store and
buy some bubble gum and that's and i
said well you know let's let's get it
and let's see how it goes let's try it
anyway and as you can probably see
they figured out what to do with the
bubblegum
right i mean what one thing that i have
learned that i've truly learned this
year in traveling but the united states
and internationally is that
people are people everywhere
students are students everywhere and
teachers are teachers everywhere i mean
we are all connected by the same dreams
and flaws and hopes and challenges i
mean it's all just truly universal we're
really not all that different we're all
working towards the same goals and this
was just kind of a moment for me that i
guess if i had to pick one out for the
year that just really set in is really
powerful and and not many days go by i
don't think about these students
on the other side of the world
with with nothing
i mean they're living in makeshift
trailers and their teachers are living
in trailers and they're trying to go
about everyday life and do everything
that we're trying to do and master all
these skills and all this curriculum
with absolutely nothing and and it's a
very powerful moment
you
know i get caught up in a lot of the
debates
on education
one of the debates that i get caught up
is you know i haven't students change
you know you say students are students
everywhere but these are different
students now they're different people
these are digital natives you know
they've all grown up with all this
technology and somehow that makes them
different and you know that's a long
debate and we can certainly get into it
and as i said to students today i mean
technology has done amazing things for
all of us and we'll continue to do so i
embrace technology i've seen it do
amazing things for students with special
needs but the bottom line is when you
think about everything that we want for
our students i mean a computer cannot
talk a student out of dropping a class
and a piece of technology cannot inspire
a child to be the first in their family
to go to college
and i don't know of any gadget that can
teach a student to see beyond himself
so yes there's technology
there are tools of technology but there
are teachers and there are people and
that's where the real power is it's it's
a people enterprise and we need as much
power people power as we can get
you know as i said people ask me you
know why did you even do this you know
you came to princeton and all you're
going to be as a teacher and i know that
that's not unique to princeton that that
that
message
is conveyed on many many college
campuses and universities across the
country that if you're going to be
somebody you've got to be something
other than a teacher had the opportunity
to go back to princeton
and visit the school where i originally
started to volunteer
and go back to my roots and this is a
photograph taken almost 20 years ago
and
i actually connected with my experience
from japan because when i was
volunteering at the new jersey school
for the deaf we really didn't have what
we needed either and as if you look at
the countertops we're doing a physics
lab and we're using hot wheels cars and
we're using track to try to do force
experiments and acceleration because as
teachers that's what we do we do what we
need to do and we scrounge for materials
when we need them had a chance in at
that visit in february to reunite with
my cooperating teacher we were
reminiscing about how we used to to beg
for materials this was back in the day i
say back in the day says 1994. this was
back in the day
i'm i'm actually if you're really good
i'm old enough to say back in my day you
know this was when film for cameras used
to come in those containers do you know
what i'm talking about some of you don't
even know what i'm talking about there's
little black containers with the gray
lids and i remember that we used to go
and we used to we used to beg these
stores that developed film and we'd say
hey before you don't just throw those
things out can you donate those to the
school because if we could have those
little containers we could change the
mass of the pennies inside we can hang
them on strings and do pendulum
experiments i mean you know what i was
doing back in 1994 wasn't so different
than what i was doing in japan in the
tsunami region just just making do and
trying to bring the best possible
education that we could to the kids it's
interesting we brought over some gate
timers at the time the wooden
contraptions you see on the wall there
and you see the surprise look at my face
to find out that they're still using
those same gait timers 16 years later
after i volunteered at the school and i
think that's what's the really amazing
thing about teaching is that you just
have this you leave this footprint you
just have this impact everywhere you go
and often you never know what that
impact is because you never hear about
it i mean how would i have known if i
hadn't visited that school 16 years
later that they're still using the same
gait timers but that's the thing for all
of you who go into teaching or you're
thinking about going into teaching you
think oh well i don't know if i'm gonna
make i mean you make a difference the
minute you walk in the door
the minute you step in the door you
start making a difference and all the
energy that you pour into it comes back
to you and it's really amazing to be
part of that continuum and that history
you know at princeton had the
opportunity to visit with some
professors from the teacher preparation
program a lot of people think that
because i went to princeton i'm tfa
right
princeton teach for america right
i'm not tfa teacher prep because when i
decided to be a teacher i decided to be
a teacher i decided to make that
commitment and i decided to pour my life
into it and i knew that i was going to
do it for more than two years and make
the biggest difference that i could
had the chance to meet with the teacher
preparation students at princeton and
kind of dismayed to find out that not
much has changed the same social
pressure that i felt not to go into
teaching
20 years ago is the same social pressure
that they feel now not to go into
teaching and i know that there are
people in this room who can relate to
that phenomenon and the question always
comes up what do we do about that very
very difficult to change public
perception once it gels and i don't have
a great answer for that question had the
opportunity to tour their new chemistry
facility got together with my chemistry
professors
from years ago had a great discussion
about stem and how it's progressed and
in the nicest possible way
said at the end you know well michelle
this is really great and it's fantastic
you've achieved all this but if you just
wanted to be a teacher you didn't need
to come to princeton
and round and round the conversation
goes again because it's it's so
ingrained but what's very interesting i
think is as a society we really like to
talk out of both sides of our mouths
because on the one hand we say we want
the absolute best possible and the
brightest teachers for our students
and i haven't heard anybody say any
different i have not been anywhere in
this country where anybody says oh yeah
you know it's okay if we don't have
great teachers that's all right
absolutely everybody wants the best
teacher for their child
it doesn't matter where you're from what
your political affiliation is nobody
says it's okay not to have a great
teacher on the other hand of the coin we
take people who have the qualifications
and the interest and the background and
all the personal skills who want to go
into teaching they say why are you doing
that
so again it's a very interesting paradox
and of course i've been completely
caught up in that particular
conversation you know people ask me what
it is about teaching that i love so much
that makes it so difficult talked about
it a little bit today but i think what's
really important i know to all teachers
is
yes we all have
advanced and often multiple degrees yes
we can juggle lots of balls in the
classroom and we can
solve problems and we know our content
and we can you know master the
curriculum and we can do this and that
but the bottom line is what we have to
be
on a daily basis all the time every day
without a break and i think when the
teacher in china said you know teaching
is tiring
you know the first thing that came to my
mind wasn't the paper grading and it
wasn't the meetings and it wasn't the
curriculum and the planning lessons it
was all these things that you have to be
all day every day everything from
passionate to creative to engaging to
dedicated and fearless and you're
pouring your energy into other people
all the time and you're left at the end
of the day with absolutely nothing
and you're just completely drained and
all you want to do is go to bed and take
a nap and you wonder how you're going to
get up the next day and do it all again
but then you think about the students
and you know that they're going to feed
that energy right back into you and and
that's what gets you out of bed to do it
all again
you know i think my biggest pet peeve as
i've traveled is to hear a teacher say
i'm just a teacher
really
i'm just a teacher
and again we don't have time at the
moment to go into all the things that a
teacher has to be but i'm just a teacher
actually it's i've asked teachers to
make just a simple change to that
statement i mean i am a teacher
i am a teacher
and it's it's quite a difficult sell
sometimes to explain what that's all
about and again people can only listen
for so long and everybody wants it in a
sound bite well in conclusion here
there's this very interesting contest
where they asked
people to send in in six words
what it means to be a teacher
again sound bite culture right six words
and i went to the website and i looked
at all the different entries and then
some of them were very uh nifty and
impressive and catchy for example one of
them said teachers hold ladders that
students climb there's your six words
teachers hold ladders that students
climb that's a nice image there was
another one that was a little bit more
sciency that said
teachers point out rockets no i'm sorry
point out the stars provide rockets
okay again i like the scientific imagery
but i was reading through the list and
there was one that really made me sit
back in my chair that i thought yes
this is what describes in six words
teachers and and nearly everybody
engaged in education
attributed into somebody named amanda w
in nevada
and i really appreciate her words
yes
selflessly dedicated to someone else's
success
that is what it means to be a teacher
selflessly dedicated to someone else's
success
and for me
there's been a lot of those someone
else's
i knew a long time ago that i was going
to need something to remind me why i
decided to become a teacher first place
because it's a very very demanding job
there are days it's extremely difficult
for me to get out of bed at 4 45 in the
morning which is the time that i have to
get up to make it to my school on time
to teach
and there are nights when i listen to
the news and i hear the conversation
about education how negative it's all
become and and i just want to run from
it and that's just the honest truth
but then i get to school and i know that
this is waiting for me
and i decided a long time ago not to
cover my bulletin boards with messages
or calendars or postings but just to
cover my bulletin boards with the faces
of students
so that i would always remember why i
decided to be a teacher and what i'm
doing there and i go to my classroom and
i see pictures of students from the
school for the deaf who won their
academic world championship i see
pictures of students who have gone on to
be scientists and engineers i see
pictures of students who have gone on to
be teachers i see pictures of students
who have given their lives for our
country
and it's been a great honor for me as i
have traveled this year to represent
students and represent teachers and to
really spread the message that
you know public education keyword is
public it's for everybody and it's a
human business and everybody has
something to contribute i mean you don't
have to be the national teacher of the
year to take an interest in a child's
education
right you don't have to be a chemistry
teacher to get involved with your local
community or whatever is going on with
stem or science
i mean everybody has the ability to
inspire students
to see beyond themselves
that it's really a human business and
it's that human factor that makes all
the difference thank you so much
for allowing me to be here tonight
absolutely i mean my first year my first
full year of teaching was actually my
public
school classroom
and you're right you're probably going
to have it's very likely you'll have a
difficult situation you might have
between 30 and 40 students in class you
might be pushing a cart
you might not have enough books enough
desks i mean again there's this
when you start off we all have this
starry-eyed image of going into the
classroom and changing the world and how
magical it's all going to be and then
you realize you're dealing with people
and you're dealing with difficult
situations and often not the resources
that you need
the first year of teaching is tough but
the 15th year of teaching is tough too
in a different way
i think the hardest part when you step
into that classroom for the first time
is realizing that despite public
perception this is not an easy job
and it will consume you 24 hours a day
because not only does it take that long
just to get the lessons planned and the
materials together and and you know make
sure you're grading the work and
analyzing your data and attending
whatever meeting you have to do and
maybe you're in extracurricular
activities and you're trying to keep up
with latest technology and curriculum
and all that it's 24 7.
not to mention the fact that you care
about kids you know so you're laying
awake at night like thinking about
johnny or bobby or thinking about you
know what you did or said or didn't
and it's all
consuming and a lot of people
bolt
after the first few years because it's
not what they expected
and i think it's really important to
understand that as you embark on your
first classroom is hey it's not gonna be
easy
and and b if you're the type of person
that really loves a challenge
and
not just a challenge but something
that's dynamic every day is different
every student is different nothing that
you do will ever work the same way twice
i mean i'm a 15-year teacher and i'm
still every day looking at every class
as a new class and every kid's a
different kid and if you love that sort
of complexity
then you will love teaching
and the energy that you put into it will
come back to you and that's what will
feed you and keep you going you know
it's like i say to my budding scientists
i said if you're the type of person who
wants immediate answers you probably
shouldn't be in research science because
there are people who work their entire
lives on a scientific problem and
just take one step towards the overall
picture because they love the process
and they love the process and that's why
they do it i think it's the same thing
in teaching
you have to be able to embrace the chaos
you embrace the chaos and you realize
that you are making a difference right i
mean teachers change lives
they really do not every day is a kodak
moment
and sometimes uh those those moments are
few and far between
but you're changing lives and and it's a
great honor to change a life even one
life
and as a teacher you have the
opportunity to change so many
so keep that in mind
and put that message on your desk
selflessly dedicated to someone else's
success and that will keep you going
through that first year great question
and good luck to you
that's a fantastic point i mean
everybody's involved everybody has a
role and thank goodness for that because
kids need all the support that they can
get and you brought up parents i mean
talking about parents that's like a
whole other hour-long discussion it
really is and i mean parents are the
most important people in a child's life
and that's just a fact and nobody has
greater power than the parent to
positively affect a child's academic
success and one of the things that i
talk about with new teachers is that
it's important to sort out like parent
contact and parent involvement like
these days a lot of times we think well
you know i posted a message on my web
page so i contacted the parent and and
that's good enough that's not good
enough we have to involve our parents
you're right because they play a big
role for me it's very interesting
because a lot of parents think they
can't be involved with what i do because
i teach ap chemistry and a lot of
parents either say well you know i never
took chemistry i took chemistry but i
hated it i took chemistry 25 years ago
and they feel that they can't be
involved so it's my job as a teacher yes
to bring them in meaning one of the
things i try to do is i try to give my
parents a list of ways they can be
involved like a menu of options for how
they can support their child and it's
the same thing with community members i
think as as teachers
we need to
do a better job of reaching out and
telling people you know here's what we
need from our parents here's what we
need for a community because often
people want to help and they just don't
know how because it hasn't been spelled
out for them obviously your building
administrator has a huge impact i've
been very fortunate to work with
administrators who have encouraged me to
take risks
i mean that's how i get you know 100
kids into ap chemistry because i've been
allowed to take risks that's how i went
to the maryland school for the deaf and
brought them ap chemistry for the first
time because there was a principal who
said let's forge ahead let's do it be
the flagship program
you know so yes the administrator has an
absolutely important role everybody has
a role to play you're right and and to
be honest
even with technology which you think
would bring us all together to
communicate more effectively
it's got to be that face to face you got
to have that face to face the technology
doesn't do it for us it really doesn't
it's a great question
absolutely and and the goal of the ap
class is not just to pass the test
you're absolutely right and again just
to use the example that i use for the
conversation i don't care how many your
kids pass the ap exam if they can't also
do this and that's a hard sell to
students sometimes especially in in
these economic times because students
and their parents will associate that
score with a gpa which gets associated
with a scholarship which gets you into
college so the conversation has really
changed in the past few years with even
more of an emphasis and a pressure from
students and parents to make sure that
teachers are helping them get that score
but let me let me turn my answer around
in a slightly different fashion because
you talked about the score issue
i accept students into my class who i
know their prognosis on the exam is not
assured
i mean it's just what i decided to do
many years ago i just decided to cast
the widest net
and i'll use one student as an example
she took my class it was a big risk you
know she didn't have all the skills she
needed and in the end
she did not pass the test she got she
got a two
and so if on that basis she is a failure
and so am i
right
but if you look at the bigger picture
and i think that's what you're getting
at the bigger picture that student
because of what she learned in my class
and again that focus on the critical
thinking and the communication all those
other skills
she carried all that with her to her
next ap science class and she was
successful and then she carried that on
to be the first in her family to go to
college and major in stem so when i say
take risks i mean you're right it's not
all about the test and if we go through
and we say oh well you're going to pass
the test and you're not then we're not
tapping a lot of the potential that
exists in our students especially in our
english language learners and students
who are for whatever reason
a bit behind in their education because
not all students follow the same
sequence so that's an excellent question
and is absolutely about more than the
test score but
that's a harder and harder sell these
days when so much is being tied to those
scores everything from gpas and
scholarships to teacher evaluation and
teacher pay
and in those conversations test scores
are not the sole indicator but but
they're being brought in as a big part
but what's really being discussed in the
educator effectiveness discussion is
multiple measures i mean yes the content
and test scores it's going to be a piece
it's going to be there the growth
however we're going to do it however
we're not going to get around it it's
going to be there and that's troublesome
because you know for a class like mine i
have a test it's kind of easy to do what
about all these untested areas like what
does that look like for for fourth grade
art or pe and how's that going to tie in
but it's going to be there one way or
the other they haven't figured it all
out yet but you know they're looking at
a lot of other different things
um in terms of how teachers you know
effectively manage their classes and how
they relate to students and all of this
but see i think the real sticking point
of the issue is that we're limiting
ourselves by using the term effective in
the first place
because i don't strive to be an
effective teacher
i strive to be an extraordinary teacher
and i have from the beginning and i
think the problem with the effectiveness
discussion is that we're trying to
figure out how to put it on a piece of
paper in a rubric
we're trying to code it because it's got
to be fair and understandable and
transparent and concrete and all that
when really what we want and i say the
collective we when you think about what
people want from their teachers they
don't just want effective they want that
magical teacher who can inspire and and
and you know again teach students all
these skills to see beyond themselves
all these intangible things that we want
so badly from our teachers that never
finds its way on to the checklist
and i think there are different ways we
can go about that i mean for example in
my own experience as an educator i've
never been asked until i started the
teacher of the year program what do you
do
that you consider special what do you do
to connect with kids i've been asked
what committees i've been on and what
courses i've taken for my professional
development but nobody's ever nobody
ever really asked me
why why do how do you get 100 kids in ap
chemistry
what is your philosophy what do you say
what you do and i think we need to take
it to that next level whatever this next
educator effectiveness is going to look
like has to account for the intangibles
because otherwise we will never have
that that higher model of what we want
our teachers to be so the people even
know what to strive for that we're
always kind of limited by something that
goes on paper and that's kind of what
i'm trying to push in the discussion but
it's it's far from over i mean most
states are just still waiting through
what they're going to do and what
they're going to pilot and it's it's all
very
um
tentative and still very much in the
works
that's a great question
sure absolutely i think i saw that right
away when i worked with the students you
know at the school for the deaf i think
that students who are in particular
missing one sense are that much more in
tune with their other senses and i
noticed for example i taught five years
at urbana high school hearing students
okay and they reacted to things in a
certain way in the lab
when i went to the school for the deaf
doing the same labs those students saw
things that my other students never saw
that i never saw because they
they were so much more in tune with the
visual and just the hands-on nature that
they tapped into
aspects that i overlooked or that my
hearing students frankly didn't
appreciate so yes i would say especially
in the case where students are missing a
sense
that they're that much more in tune with
their other senses and that enables them
to experience to an even greater degree
you know another example would be a
student who
has severe dysgraphia
which means they have a lot of writing
processing difficulties those students
are often very verbal and they
participate extensively in class and
just by participating and hearing your
own voice and asking questions and
trying to process things verbally
brought them a whole different
understanding than students who were
just used to you know reading and
writing and reading and writing and
never heard it in their own voice
because they didn't participate to the
extent that they probably should have so
i think yes there's always some over
compensation
when there's a limitation and often that
that benefits the student
honestly i think the most exceptional
teachers are the ones who who really
reach beyond their content area and even
reach beyond the skills that we talk
about and really focus on the
interpersonal relationships with the
students and i know that sounds very
muddy and murky in our relationships you
know that's the key i mean it's the
teachers who can really find a way in a
class of 36 to make a student feel like
they're the only one in the class
i mean
that's really magical and it's very
tricky to pull off but there are
teachers who do it and i know that they
can because i often read
uh recommendations that students have
written about teachers and they'll often
say things like that you know that
teacher made me feel like the only
person in the class you know it kind of
goes beyond even caring it's just to
make somebody feel that special and to
be that in tune and very interesting
those students often say you know i
really don't know what it is about that
teacher that makes everybody want to
work so hard again it's that intangible
factor i mean there are just people who
are very gifted and really born to do
this job and that's that's really
special and it's something that can be
emulated you know again if we focus on
it you know if we focus on it and
realize the importance of relationships
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu